near-death experiences hypothermia and
an icebreaker no one saw coming oh and
then there was the time the whole crew
was drugged
one of the most bizarre things to happen
on the Titanic set happened while
filming the framing narrative centered
around Bill Paxton's character Brock
Lovett and his search of the wreck of
the Titanic Marilyn McAvoy a background
painter who worked on Titanic spoke to
Vice about the incident which occurred
in 1996 when some cast and Crews sat
down to enjoy a clam chowder lunch there
was only one problem it was spiked with
PCP those affected including James
Cameron and actor Bill Paxton were
rushed to the hospital both Kate Winslet
and Leonardo DiCaprio were spared to
this eventful dinner since they weren't
required for this Canadian shoot he said
what did you eat the clam chowder and I
thought well yeah I had a couple of
bowls and about that time I started
feeling it Marilyn McAvoy recalls how
the evening began with people going for
seconds and thirds of the Chowder
because it tasted so good everyone was
having a lot more than they usually
would soon people started tripping and
once they realized what was happening
Cameron allegedly went up to his room to
make himself throw up and stop the
hallucinogen from taking over McAvoy
described how the crew was in the
hospital all night as some people were
having a bad trip she said it became
pretty chaotic people had a lot of
energy some were in wheelchairs flying
down the hallways people were playing
hacky sack Bill Paxton also opened up to
Larry King about the incident describing
the hospital scene that night in much
the same way you see some people are
freaking out some people are Congo
dancing some people are euphoric I I
knew I was pretty Stoned on her end
McAvoy said it all seemed like a dream
and that her experience wasn't too bad
unfortunately for the crew they never
caught the perpetrator resulting in that
entire night going down as one of the
weirdest onset moments once the Titanic
sinks Jack freezes in The Frigid Waters
but Rose manages to stay alive and flag
down a nearby boat looking for survivors
it's a tragic ending but Rose's
shivering tears weren't pure acting it
was cold as hell in that water in 2017
Kate Winslet appeared on The Late Show
with Stephen Colbert and revealed that
when shooting this scene in the water
she got hypothermia yeah I
she further explained that even though
this was all supposed to be pretend
movie Magic there was so much water that
the crew couldn't heat it all up hey
maybe if DiCaprio had just climbed up on
that piece of wood to keep her warm nah
never mind there's no way there was room
for him no possible way
it turns out Kate Winslet suffered quite
a bit during filming in a 1997 interview
with the Los Angeles Times Winslet
revealed a variety of injuries she got
on set bruises gashes and a chipped
elbow she also described the moment when
she almost drowned during one scene what
makes this even more bizarre is the fact
that Cameron didn't notice and kept
directing as he was completely oblivious
to her near-death experience the scene
in question takes place when Rose and
Jack are running through the ship as
water is gushing in they tried to find
an Escape Route but soon get trapped in
by a closed gate with water pouring in
on them once the scene was cut the
production team opened the gate to allow
DiCaprio and Winslet through however her
coat got caught on the iron bars and she
was submerged in the water wenzlit
described the experience to the Los
Angeles Times saying I had no breath
left I thought I'd burst and Jim just
said okay let's go again that was his
attitude I didn't want to be a wimp so I
didn't complain well I'm fine
I'll be fine
really although Cameron realized a few
minutes later that Winslet was feeling
shaken by The Experience he wanted to
get back into it and shoot the scene
again comparing it to getting back on a
horse after a fall The Show Must Go On
after all
for many the staircase in Titanic is an
iconic symbol of rose and Jack's love
early in the film Jack waits for Rose at
the bottom of the staircase to escort
her to dinner with her family he's blown
away when he sees her looking fancy and
beautiful and the Romantic tension
between them is palpable in the final
scene of the movie Rose passes away and
the staircase appears again reuniting
her with Jack and all of the others lost
on the Titanic both are beautiful and
emotional moments as they show the
Journey of Jack and Rose's relationship
culminating with their final Embrace in
the afterlife however behind the scenes
of this romantic tale is a puzzling
story in 2017 Cameron reflected on his
time filming Titanic in National
Geographic's Titanic 20 years later with
James Cameron when looking back at the
iconic staircase Cameron recalled the
staircase has got a steel footing then
when we sank the ship it lifted wood is
buoyant it ripped off that footing and
it all floated up and it actually pinned
two stunt players fortunately they
weren't hurt but it was a pretty scary
moment the staircase was built to
replicate the actual Grand stairs that
were award the famous vessel so perhaps
it brought some of its bad luck with it
Brett Baker Leonardo DiCaprio's photo
double in Titanic spoke to Vanity Fair
in 2016 about his experience making the
film Baker was a struggling actor and
was thrilled to join the project even
though the role wasn't exactly what he
trained for as a photo double Baker's
job was to silently take DiCaprio's
place in shots where you couldn't see
his face to give the star a break from
more tedious work Baker's presence in
Titanic is undetectable but he remembers
how nervous he was to meet Cameron for
the first time since he is both shorter
and older than DiCaprio luckily Cameron
believed he looked enough like DiCaprio
that it would work Baker looks back
fondly on his time on the Titanic set
saying most actors don't get their big
breaks starring in one of the biggest
films of all time plus the photo double
life got interesting thanks to all of
the Teen fans waiting by the studio gate
hoping to catch a glimpse of DiCaprio
during the filming of Titanic the Leo
craze was in full swing security would
Usher DiCaprio out the back to avoid the
fans and Baker would be brought out
front for everyone to gush over turning
him into a real-life photo double for
the star as Baker recalls to Vanity Fair
the fans went berserk screaming looking
inside the window waving their pieces of
paper for an autograph I don't know if
anyone knew that was going on at the
gate every morning at least he got his
own little fan club during filming
actors have been known to take things
from set from time to time think of it
less as stealing and more is holding
onto a piece of memorabilia that
commemorates the time they spent filming
it's understandable when one goes
through Blood Sweat and Tears to make a
film that they feel like they deserve a
little something for their troubles
aside from their massive paycheck of
course when slit did almost drown and
get hypothermia maybe it's fair to say
that she wanted to take a little
something extra on the way out in an
interview with the New York Times she
revealed that she likes saving things
from sets and during Titanic she snagged
some jewelry she explained I did take a
pair of rose's earrings but somewhere I
lost one it's a fitting story since
Titanic itself is framed around a search
for lost jewelry a necklace that of
course gets lost in the ocean at the end
it's no secret that Leonardo Dicaprio
and Kate Winslet have enjoyed a
decades-long friendship ever since
starring a star-crossed lovers in
Titanic the two have freely shown each
other their admiration and support over
the years a decade after Titanic the two
starred in the post-war romantic drama
Revolutionary Road Winslet talked about
her friendship with DiCaprio in an
interview with the guardian noting that
they've known each other for half their
lives she said he's my friend my really
close friend we're bonded for Life
when's lit won the Golden Globe for best
actress in 2009 for Revolutionary Road
and gushed about her co-star in Her
off-the-cuff speech for his part
DiCaprio has described how Winslet broke
the ice between the two right off the
bat and the official behind the scenes
book of the film at w Marsh's James
Cameron's Titanic DiCaprio shared their
bizarre first encounter that did just
that the first scene he shot was the one
where he draws naked Rose DiCaprio
explained Winslet had no shame with it
she wanted to break the ice a little
beforehand so she flashed me I wasn't
prepared for that so she had one up on
me I was pretty comfortable after that a
1998 Rolling Stone profile on Winslet
detailed how things snowballed from
there with Winslet and DiCaprio spending
the rest of the shoot pranking each
other and forming a very comfortable
relationship Winslet explained we were
kind of the two goofy kids on the set we
do the most ridiculous things to each
other he be tickling me groping me
winding me up and I'd be doing the same
thing back sort of grabbing his bum
Caprio discussed the seriousness of
their friendship on set as well saying
she was my best friend for seven months
we'd unload the stresses of the shoot to
each other vent to each other watch out
for each other Kate was just the perfect
person to work with because she was very
much one of the guys and it would have
been much harder without her we were
Partners
oh that was better you got to work on it
really try and honk it up and get some
body to it you know you gotta
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]